hello
everyone so I'm going to jump right into
it today we are going to talk to an
indie developer about how they managed
to find funding for their indie game
after working as a solo developer for
quite some time hello hello how are you
I'm good thank you how are you doing
tonight yes I'm all good I'm all good uh
so Chris is uh making a game called
Focus find and and uh I'll let you
introduce yourself so please introduce
yourself and your game uh my name is
Chris Jarvis I'm an indie game developer
I've been working on Focus find my
little indie game uh since
2020 um it's a psychological sci-fi
thriller puzzle narrative game where you
can wish list uh on Steam now and yeah
that's that's me and the game in a
nutshell basically um so I want to know
uh what is your current development
situation as it stands now so as it
stands now I'm uh effectively a
consultant for a company called jump bun
Studio they've come into a situation
where they're working with partners and
they're in a position where they can
fund the development of focus find so I
am now working as the project lead on
Focus find um did you always know that
you wanted to make games uh I well not
always no I kind of I first wanted to do
games back um in 2010ish 20 2009 I was
just um working full-time for BT and I
was just going through the ucast website
looking for what to study at University
because I had enough work and I want
just wanted to go to university uh and
then I saw that the games courses were
like video games courses and I was like
ah okay and then I saw that one of the
games courses was in Norwich which is
where where my friend was studying and I
thought oh I could go to UNI with my
friend and I could study video games
that sounds cool and so it was then that
I thought that could be a job after uni
I then briefly worked uh for Sony um as
as an internship for about three months
um that didn't end so well that's a
whole another that's a whole another uh
podcast episode or um uh stream and that
was that was AAA so that was son in in
uh in Cambridge working on Killzone
mercenary for the PS
Vita and so I I kind of fell out of love
with games I thought if this is it this
is not really what I want to do and then
it wasn't until um
lockdown uh and Co that I thought that
games was what brought me so much joy
and I was had this creative mind and I
had all these ideas for games and I just
thought that it's better to try and
strive to do something that makes you
feel fulfilled than than try to stay
where I was in the current job which
wasn't giving me any fulfillment anymore
so I actually started working like in my
spare time on my first game where I was
like ah okay yep that's what I want to
do so it wasn't until I tried it so when
I was what 30 that I thought yep found
it oh wow that's so cool that's really
good to know though cuz people always
tend to think that if you haven't got
your your life figured out by 30 then
you're doomed
so I cuz I was going to ask you why you
chose to become an indie Dev over a more
traditional AAA career cuz that's
usually you know the more traditional
route but I guess you tried that route
and it didn't work out it didn't work
out long story short I basically went
through the process of taking Sony to
court over unpaid internship they
settled out of court and so I had this
huge massive court case looming over me
it was very stressful lots lots of
anxiety and I didn't think that another
Studio was going to touch me with a
barge pole in any case anyway also I
didn't really enjoy the job as much as
such um considering how much stress was
involved and I would have had to have
packed up my life like I had a a partner
and I've had a kid and so I didn't want
to move and where I lived there was no
studios so this was before you know this
was before like International Studios
and working from home was a real big
thing so this was um was it 20 13 uh
2013 so that wasn't on the cards yeah so
it wasn't on the cards it wasn't a thing
so i' never thought that there was an
option for me so I never knew that like
having an office in my house working on
my own little game could earn me money
wow I hope that answered the question it
it did it did thanks for being so open
and honest um I really appreciate that
and I'm really glad that you managed to
rekindle your love for games again as an
indie developer cuz that sounds like a
very stressful situation um and I would
completely understand if you didn't want
to make games over again but you have
and now you're here so congrats to you
yeah that's the thing we change all the
time um and what we might have wanted to
do when we were kids is not always
necessarily what we want to do when
we're older uh I actually only found
that out like a few months ago my
therapist was like just because it made
you happy 20 years ago doesn't mean you
have to make you happy now and I was
like w mind BL and your games your games
change I think your games definitely
change you you always have your
favorites The Nostalgia but you your my
preference for games and my appetite for
games has changed and I would I love
just weekend games now now that I'm like
a dad with a mortgage and a full-time
job in games when I play games I just
want the smallest game possible so like
Little Indie Games is right up my street
so in your own words uh explain what
your game is about explain Focus find so
uh Focus find is primarily a narrative
uh linear driven game you play as Adam
and you're a floating orb essentially
and everything you see and hear and
everything you can interact with um is
you visualizing and processing your own
mind um you travel through the five
stages of grief and
uh you're trying to remember your past
in order to fix your mind and you're
being Guided by a doctor who's set up
the in interface um so it's a Sci-Fi
game in that respect so it's sort of uh
dystopian future where people can sort
of fix their their damaged brain through
this
machine um and yeah you play this
floating orb and you can get um you have
to solve puzzles and then collect
memories to process the game but because
it's a psychological Thriller game not
everything is as it seems you can't
really trust what you see and what you
hear um and there are twists and turns
and
Revelations um and the feedback I've got
from the team when they're working on
the game they've um noted those Thriller
moments in the oh my God I can't believe
that sort of thing that's happening so
that that's kind of the game in a
nutshell so it's like a yeah suspenseful
Thriller game oh that's it sounds like
it's um it's been updated quite a lot
since I played it last cuz I played a
demo a little while ago so it's pretty
cool you're one of the F you're one of
the few people there's literally handful
of people that played like what we call
that now is the Legacy game so we're
calling that the Legacy version and this
is like Focus find 2.0 which is
answering the question if you so that's
what I made was what I could make as a
solo Dev and now Focus find is is what
can I make with some people helping me
out uh which included time to write
narrative uh funding to get some voice
actors so three voice actors that are
going to be uh in the game because
before it was just me um just like like
self-actualizing like realizing what was
happening in the world and it I mean it
was interesting for like 10 minutes but
it wasn't really a narrative you could
like sink teeth into but now there are
characters and there's um memories and
that there's scenes and a story that
develops over time so is this your first
indie game yes it is really yeah yeah
which is kind of crazy because people
don't usually uh get get this amount of
freedom and funding and create freedom
and working with a team on their first
game so I'm extremely fortunate to be in
the position I'm in but this is yeah
this is like the first idea I ever had
for a game so it's impressive the the
best piece of advice I can give to
people is don't don't do what I did I
should have just made a tiny little game
and released it what I've done is I've
done what every first game uh Game Dev
does which is make the smallest simplest
thing they can which is like a puzzle
platformer game and I'm releasing it on
Steam but puzzle platformer games don't
sell very well on Steam because probably
because there's no appetite for it
financially and also it's everyone's
first game so I think the algorithm
tries to steer people away from those
sort of games there are the there are
the there are the runaway successes
there are like your uh insides and your
um uh Hollow nights and things like that
it's an uphill struggle to fight against
the algorithm to get this uh to get this
game done I think even though the fact
that you're like working on your your
first proper indie game and you've
gotten it this far is a bloody
achievement cuz I think a lot of people
um myself included would just like get
bored and move on to another project or
whatever not to say that one is is good
or bad but um yeah I mean kudos to you
this is yeah it's really good yeah so
actually it moves on to the next
question which is how long have you been
developing this indie game if it's your
first and only one i' heard that the
best way to learn like Co building and
game development was just to make a
little game yeah so that's what I that's
what I decided to do um and so that was
August 20120 and then um continued on
just in my spare time so evenings and
weekends um you know Saturdays couldn't
really go out do much so I just spent
spent as much time as I could uh honing
my skills and then it wasn't until March
uh this year 2023 that um I went
fulltime uh on on Focus find so it's
only been about seven months worth of
full-time work actually so yeah about
seven months of fulltime and then what
like two years of doing it in your two
years yeah two years of spare time yeah
yeah that's that's not that long you
know I thought I thought you were going
to say up been on it for like five years
but in your spare time um I guess you
must have I guess lot down kind of
worked for you didn't it because I was
thinking you must have had a really uh
concrete kind of schedule for yourself
to make sure that you kept working on it
but because of lockdown I guess that
kind of gave it to you anyway yeah it
kind of made it really easy like I
didn't have many other commitments um I
was kind of forced to it was either that
or watch TV and play games which I did
plenty of as well but I had my set
amount of times you know my my set
schedule days yeah sat mornings that
would be you know make myself breakfast
and then get to work really I want to
say it sounds really nice but it was
lockdown I know it was really hard for
everyone but it does kind of sound
really nice it was a bit of an escape
and it was a bit of a a bit of a glimmer
of hope if you like it was something
that I could put put my time and energy
into it was something I could control
and it was something that was like
building my future and it was like
investing in myself so that was what I
kept telling myself as I was doing it
cuz it it is a SLO and being solo Dev is
is a SLO mentally so you have to keep
telling yourself those things to to get
through it I've got this question how do
you stick to one idea because I a lot of
people ask me all the time how do I find
one idea and stick to it um if you only
had Focus finders your idea that's
that's fine um but you probably had
feature creep everyone has feature creep
so yeah how did you stick to one idea
Focus find is is basically feature creep
so Focus find like the Legacy version
that you played that was what one person
could do with one person's like
abilities um and now what we're making
with a few people is feature creep
except it came with a budget creep as
well so it it's not uh it's not too bad
I did get distracted and I did think of
other game ideas and the best advice I
can give is to like indulge them like if
you're getting tired if you're if you're
a solo Indie Dev and it's your spare
time and you've got ideas that you want
to prototype they are valuable they're
never going to be a waste of time
they're going to set you back on what
you're working on for sure but it's
always a good idea to have like a
catalog of prototypes and Pitch decks
and things that you can work on and
usually with creative people they're
going to be something different all my
prototypes and ideas and things were
like the opposite of of of focus find
that's that's but you got to keep in
mind that I've chosen Focus find is the
simple quickest game I can make that's
what's going to be made first and you
come back to the prototypes after Focus
find is done so that's um that's how you
keep yourself like on track so allow
yourself the freedom to explore the
ideas that you have but with it in mind
that you are going to go back to your
initial idea either um so would you
either see if you can put anything from
the Prototype you've just done into the
current idea or just so that you have
the Prototype there for like future
purposes if you ever need it for a
portfolio or whatever yeah so the the
other prototypes will be like will
become eventually a c the catalog of the
games I'm going to make so they're
they're going to eventually be those
next games so I don't want to
incorporate them into Focus find um
because I want to like differentiate
them from Focus find uh so that's kind
of that kind of helps against feature
creep as well because if you think of a
mechanic you think oh that's a really
cool mechanic you could put it into your
next game you don't need to put it into
into your current game and that keeps
the dev time down on on your current
game um yeah try to keep it as small as
possible you know what that's really
good advice because you're always here
you know trying to try and stick to one
idea try to like ignore the other ones
or or write them down um but I think
yeah as for creatives it's really nice
when you get that spark and excitement
of a new idea especially when you're
making something like a game that spans
years and it will span years even if
you're working on it
fulltime um so you don't want to squish
that excitement and that flame and um
yeah that's that's quite interesting for
me actually as well because I I always
I've got so many like game design
documentation where I'll just write down
ideas but if I'm in the middle of a
project I usually force myself to not
actually Dev anything like Dev any new
ideas until I'm finished with the
current one but sometimes that can just
force me to get like not want to recck
on my current one because I'm so excited
about something new and I'm like I wish
I wish it could just be done but then
you don't enjoy the process of your
current uh piece so yeah it's
interesting thank you for sharing that
yeah the only thing that's changing is
the release date of the current project
you're doing mhm do you have any tips on
overcoming doubt as a solo Indie
developer
some of the tips I've came up with is is
understanding that failure is not the
opposite of success it's part of it it's
important to like the process of me
making this game initially started out
as um like reskilling myself and gaining
experience and regardless of what
happened with Focus find even if it just
turned into a prototype that I sheld
eventually um those skills and
experiences were still like valuable
another thing is trying to stay focused
as to why I'm making an indie game I'm
thinking of it as myself as an artist
and I'm creating a piece of art which is
going to express uh like ultimately a
piece of me for people to um you know
observe enjoy play interact with I'm not
trying to make like a hit game uh I'm
not trying to make loads of money um I'm
not even trying to make enough money to
like keep keep this going that's the
eventual goal
um but I'm just trying to make the best
game that I can with the resources that
are given with me and the amount of time
that's been given to me and um knowing
that that is what I'm supposed to be
doing and that's my end goal just like
the process of making your game yeah
then um I'm going and and find enjoyment
in that then I don't get to like hung up
on like failing like if something
happens uh and you know funding gets
pulled um or if the game doesn't make
any money and I'll have to find a job
I'm still going to be making indie games
because that's still what I'm supposed
to be doing so everything else it
doesn't really matter as long as I'm
making indie games and I can do that in
my spare time and I have done in my
spare time then I'm kind of doing what
I'm supposed to be doing and when you
say um because that's what I'm supposed
to be doing do you mean like because
that's what feeds your soul in a sense
like just makes you feel alive is that
kind of
yeah yeah when I speak to people about
the game and when people ask me about
the game and when I'm working with the
people on the game that's when I get
that sense of fulfillment something that
I know like gets me fired up and
passionate and so I'm going to be doing
it forever uh or until I lose the
passion one of the two um and whatever
capacity I'm doing that in um it doesn't
really matter so like if someone hires
me for a company and I'm doing it
doesn't really matter if I'm if I'm
working and this is a side project
doesn't really matter like obviously I
want to be doing it as much as possible
which is why I'm in this great situation
now where it's full-time yeah and I
count myself lucky um so it's just that
framework of I'm this is the part that
I'm enjoying is the making the game but
that being said I've never released a
game because this is my first game so
other people chase that feeling of
finishing a game but I I don't have that
to latch on to yet well I think it's
nice though because you are enjoying the
process and the feelings that come with
making your game
uh and the fact that you you're able to
take time out to check back in with the
why like the why at the beginning
because I think a lot of us with with
many things not just games like you know
YouTube films like whatever it is you're
making you might start something one day
just because you have an idea and it
makes you feel good and you know like
you just say you don't think about it
ever making money or you doing it
fulltime it's just like it feels nice to
you and you want to do it but then once
you start to do it for
a year or maybe more then you start to
think oh wait like expectations creep in
right external ones or maybe internal
ones that weren't there before and uh
it's it's a good
um yeah it's it's a tough thing for
people to learn but it's good for you to
take time out and reflect back on why
you wanted to start to do something in
the first place before it blows up and
becomes a massive thing because you love
something doesn't mean you should work
on it
like I enjoyed like consuming games I
didn't I enjoyed consuming AAA games
sorry I didn't particularly enjoy making
AAA games and
so like enjoying something that you
consume is different to enjoying
something you
do
yeah yeah you're going to give a lot of
people many things to think about myself
included you really are first of all how
did you I know you've touched on this a
little bit but if you just want to
clarify how did you fund your game
through your time as a solo developer so
not now how did you do it before yeah
yeah when I was a solar developer the
the the plan that I went through um
which is a solid one uh and it's one I
can like recommend is um talk about it
as much as possible uh on social media
things like Tik Tok and uh Twitter um
YouTube LinkedIn focus on a couple of
those I tried to like scatter it out as
much as possible because I thought that
if I scattered it out it would get the
best return but it's for me uh YouTube
and Tik Tok seem to be doing the best in
terms of um numbers I also run a a
podcast uh with my now workmate um Vin
um so we do the polygon Forest podcast
which you've been on um and so I was
posting my update
straight away from there some people
think oh no you should wait and you know
wait and don't release what you're
working on cuz people could take the
idea if you're a solo Indie Game Dev
that's never made a game before no one's
ever going to steal your idea it's
absolutely fine um so I was posting
there and I was starting to build a
prototype um so something to prove that
the game was fun uh and then once I
proved myself that the game was fun
people call it gray box level because
there's no art um
then you move on to like vertical slice
SL demo I basically made the demo put it
on Steam which is what you played and a
couple other streamers streamed it and
the idea behind that was to get um
interest from uh Publishers so I made a
a pitch deck so a presentation outlining
what the game is um and what I was
looking for in like a publisher but
before this like while you were making
the game and you were putting up um Tik
toks and YouTube videos and doing your
podcast um you had a job to to like how
did you pay the bills how did you pay
the rent I was just working as a Telly
sales advisor for a a pet pharmaceutical
company and it paid the bills and it
afforded me to be able to buy this um
this PC um so I have to be thankful to
the company did you did you need the PC
before you could start any of your game
development stuff I'm guessing yeah yeah
you know originally I bought the PC cuz
I was knew I was going to do a podcast
with my friend Vin so I wanted to be
able to do video editing and I thought
again that's going to be another skill
that will come in handy if I'm getting
into the games industry um and I thought
it could be it might be another way to
make a little bit of money if I if I
learned video editing so you know
reskilling myself yeah so that's why I
bought the PC and then the PC allowed me
to to use Unity yeah so to come back how
how I got the fulltime gig was was
working full-time looking for for
Publishers my friend Vin who I did the
podcast with started to work for jump
button Studios it's who you know in the
industry unfortunately which sucks but
it's true so he was an old uni friend
and then I just reached out to him
because I wanted to do a a podcast
because I was just getting bored and I I
had no game friends so I wanted to like
have an excuse to talk to my game
friends and talk about games it was like
an itch I needed to scratch um oh that's
PR cool yeah so then the the CEO the CEO
but it wasn't him it was the CEO of the
of jump button Studio watch the podcast
when it formed when the Company formed
it was just a bunch of mates getting
together to um make a game and then it's
just grown and so it was effectively his
like friend watching his friend's
podcast and then he saw the updates of
focus find that I would talk about when
I was doing the podcast so it was very
natural yeah um sort of who you know
foot in the door right place right time
they they had funding at that time a lot
of people I speak to the industry they
they've all got their unusual way into
the in in into the industry yeah it's
very rare for people like Vin who like
sent portfolios off and then eventually
got an interview but you only got an
interview because his his um concept art
went viral on Kotaku there you go so
yeah there you go yeah the best way to
get into the industry and and most
people who I've heard like get into the
industry either they know someone
already or multiple people already or
they are visible in some way and they're
they're being vulnerable they're being
open they're sharing and it's like what
you said and I I wholeheartedly agree I
think if you're making
something I understand why people say
maybe you shouldn't uh share it because
XY and Z but I think there's so many
games out there there's so many ideas
out there as well and even if I tell
someone my idea and they they made it it
would never be the same as the way I
would make it we're different human
beings our minds work differently um and
I think you have nothing to lose to to
share what you're working on um and it
only it's only ever helped me even when
I share my failures it's only ever
helped me in this industry I think I
think people in Game Dev honestly love
watching People's failures not because
they love watching people fail but
because they like to see how people um
deal with like okay um I failed here so
this is what I'm going to do next time
and uh that kind of quality is um is
what people like to see in game
development because you can't work in
Game Dev and do things right all the
time doesn't work like I don't know I'm
yet to see it at what stage did
you uh start to feel ready to look for
funding I know you said that you started
to make like a a deck and and look for
look for people um but when were you
like okay I think this is ready now
because essentially when you make
especially a game or most creative
things you could work on them forever
and they're not ready so yeah yeah I've
talked about vertical slice and I've
talked about demo and I've talked about
prototype another word for a prototype
which actually does mean something
different uh is MVP so minimal viable
product so that's the smallest amount of
video game that you could create which
proves that there's something fun and
interesting and unique and different
about the game so some people call that
a demo but a demo is for the purpose of
sharing so people can play test and you
can get data from that which shows
interest um and if there's any bugs and
to like refine the game MVP is for the
purpose of getting investment so it's to
show people like Publishers um if your
game is worth investing in so if you can
create something uh the bare minimum
amount to say yes you're taking all the
boxes for me I know you can make a game
I know it's fun uh I know you have the
ability to do it and I know that we can
sell this and make some money I made the
demo put it on Steam got people like
yourself to sort of play it in the hopes
of drumming up interest I tried to
quickly as possible to get the the demo
out so that I could I could do that so
if you if you don't have a demo um and
you've just got a prototype you still
need like a pitch deck so you still need
to work on that so you still need to
have the game fully realized from start
to finish what's going to be in it and
you need to be able to talk about it um
in a really concise exin way which
demonstrates to a company that would
invest in you what they're getting into
and what sort of game you're making and
what you need so like do you need
marketing do you need porting do you
need a dev kit so you need a pitch deck
you need a prototype or MVP or a demo
and you need the last thing as well
which is like a buzz about it so you
need wish list
you can contact Publishers before you
have these things and you can have
conversations and some people get get
deals done before there's anything like
wish lists or a demo out the important
thing to remember is that the value is a
lot less so the further to completion a
game is made the more valuable it is to
other people um so the sooner you get
funding obviously the sooner you can
become a full-time Game Dev like myself
but the the small amount of the pie
you'll you'll get and the worst deal
you'll get with like a publisher for
example getting yourself out there and
uh you know meeting people in the
industry like bis Dev people like indie
game business people it's never going to
hurt like I've I've um even though the
game's fully funded and even though I'm
working full-time I've still like taken
on uh interviews and meetings with
potential Publishers um just to talk
about the game and just talk even though
there's no way that that's going to
happen now um make connection just
because just make those connections yeah
exactly because you never know what's
going to be around the corner I do
Wonder while listening to you so you
started Focus find um purely kind of
just to learn coding um and to do
something during lockdown do you recall
kind of the time when you started to
realize oh maybe this could actually be
a game that I work on full time that I
could um you know create a demo and an
MVP for and it could I could get some
funding for this when was that time it
was it was me learning about the
business and me learning about the
process and just doing it one after the
other yeah your first things first is do
the Prototype show screenshots talk
about it on your podcast get the demo
out have something to talk about get the
pitch deck sorted like were you were you
even were you even kind of thinking
about the future of like I'm gonna be a
fulltime Dev and this can make money or
were you just like ah I might as well
because I might as well and then it just
one thing led to another and now he yeah
it was kind of one thing there to
another because I I was sending off the
pitch deck and I was contacting
Publishers like hoping to get it but it
it felt unreal it didn't feel like it
was going to happen and I was getting
rejections all the time and I had my
list of um have my list of like five
best Publishers that I thought would fit
the game the most and I would contact
them first which I shouldn't do now you
should contact a few smaller ones that
you don't want to work with just to get
used to talking to Publishers and what
the sort of deals are around some most
never got back to me because I was an
unknown Indie Dev that had never
finished a game before and so I was like
okay no one's got back to me um I'll
just finish the game as quickly as I can
and then I'll have a game under my belt
and then I'll be more valuable to
potential um like Publishers and then
and then around that sort of time when I
was feeling a bit disillusioned about
not not getting any um um not getting
any Publishers interested is when I got
the opportunity to work for jump Buton
Studio kind of is just one of those
things that happened I I thought the
traditional route is you look for a
publisher and you get a publisher I
didn't consider this other route which
is work for a company and they have the
ability to fund the game the difference
is huge between a a video game company
and a publisher so a video game company
um may or may not have a marketing arm
they may or may not have certain skills
and experience for the certain game that
you're making but on the flip side you
get lots of fre creative freedom and you
get lots of decision- making and you get
to wear a lot of hats as well so you get
to learn the ropes really quickly I will
say though it's it's very like it shows
your character that you were just even
without there doesn't seem to be a
moment where you were like I want to
make money out of this you were just
like let's get all this stuff together
and let's send this off to Publishers
and see what happens just because I
don't know to me I'm like wow that's
bold
they get it's not they get thousands
they get thousands over a year like
every publisher will get thousands of
pitch decks from people like me that are
just chances that are just trying their
luck and they'll get a few that are from
like a proper established team and they'
got to sift through all of the the
rubbish so I it's great that you did
that though because then you had all
that stuff ready when this opportunity
opened up for you um so yeah I guess I
guess the takeaway is like if you want
to in any capacity do it
if you out there watching are Solo Dev
and want to try it out then might as
well just make yourself a pitch deck
make sure you've got a m minimum viable
product uh or a demo and see what you
can do because you never know what will
happen yeah put yourself out there like
I wouldn't I wouldn't be in this
situation if I didn't do a podcast so
you have to put yourself out there for
sure I know you said this all kind of
fell into your lap uh and but before
that you were looking for funding were
you also looking for a team like how did
the team come about part of the pitch
deck was like I need a coder to help me
with some bits so it was initially going
to be like a a solo project but working
closely with a with a developer when um
jumbone Studio came along they were like
if you could have some money what would
you do and so me and Vin were able to
like sit down together have a meeting
well if if we did have artists what
could the game look like and if we had
some time to like sit down and write a
narrative what could that look like and
if you had like say three voice actors
who would the characters be and what
would they do and H how would that
affect the story and so I had this
really cool time of like having this
little indie game that was just this
tiny little thing with me talking into
my mic pretending I was going through
the stages of grief and then like
writing a script with a narrative like a
thriller mystery novel being able to
like plan the stages of like who do I
need to what what sort of artists do I
need to work with I need like a senior
Dev to help me with the code and like
having those resources available it was
a slow realization like it didn't SN in
when they were like yeah you can have
some people work on the game it was like
huh okay and those people were part of
that studio as well so yeah the company
works with lots of um like contractors
and so they've got a team of people that
come in around all different projects
quite a lot so I had uh some con a
concept start team work on the game when
when we first got the game uh at at the
studio so there was about three or four
people like concept artists like
creating concept art for the game and it
was great uh and then now I've got now
I've got two artists which were concept
artists and we're in the process of
training them up to be like asset
artists so they're creating images um in
the game what do you think maybe if
you're talking to someone else who's got
an indie game and they're thinking about
looking for funding
First Step what should that be F first
step is prototype and think you have to
really mle on an idea because if you're
going to be working on it for years
you've got to love it then throw away
throw it away if it sucks uh if it works
um then work on an MVP minimal viable
product and that will tell you whether
or not it's fun and if it's fun then you
can make a
demo you can contact Publishers at any
point and when you pull the trigger it's
going to be right for you in your
situation there's no right right time
post it on social media as much as
possible just how many times were you
rejected I only want to ask this because
I just know it's going to be a lot and
I'm sure everyone goes through a lot
there was I think there was about 30 or
so um Publishers that I contacted and
literally only a handful even got back
to me to say no um gosh that's that's
that's the standard and I when when when
the demo was available for uh on on
Steam I think it actually yeah I only
gave it out to um journalists so I
created a list of journalists yourself
was was on it so you're classed as a
journalist on my little list uh and I I
sent that out to like maybe 50 streamers
and influencers and podcasters and
people like that three three people
including yourself have have made videos
on it and and literally no one else got
back to me no one else said no thanks or
emailed back the three people that got
back to me you were one of them and the
three people that got back to me
streamed the game yeah so that's a lot a
lot of rection how did you stay
motivated then through that those
rejections just like understanding it's
a process and it's that's part of it the
more you practice failing the better
you'll get
succeeding yes love that now that you
are a
full-time Indie Dev with a little team
you got some
funding what are the current obstacles
that you face now the problems we face
at the moment in my specific situation
is um is marketing people that are in my
situation that might be funded with a
publisher a publisher will have like a
marketing arm we're like a a ragtag
group of um people that are doing jobs
that they've done for the first time the
experience is not always at the standard
that is desirable I think it's the best
way to put it we're all just trying to
do the best job we can of course I have
to do most of the marketing we're
starting to do some videos now and
there'll be some videos that are
released soon for Focus find but we
don't have like a proper marketing
strategy because we don't have anyone in
the company that's that's done indie
game marketing before that's a real
challenge that's the biggest challenge
for sure and then the other challenge is
like I said with the artists that were
concept artists they've never worked in
engine before so I'm teaching them so
there's an onboarding uh process there
getting
resources in order and processes and
stuff all the usual stuff that comes
with like a startup company but the flip
side is you're Dynamic and flexible and
you can wear many hats and you can learn
a lot of things really
quickly yeah cuz I know in like uh triaa
they can just kind of Outsource all that
and spend a lot of lot a lot of money on
marketing I think the best thing that
I've personally seen Indie developers do
is just try to form a relatable
connection
with the audience which I know is what
you've been doing with Focus find as
well I don't know and maybe you've
looked into it but I wouldn't even know
how to approach anything like E3 or you
know what well E3 Summer Games Fest you
know what what the triple what the triaa
space can do yeah like get get him on
the Xbox showcase or something like that
then obviously you need to be on the
Xbox platform I know there is um double
fine uh host some sort of Indie showcase
but even getting on that I'm sure is
very difficult yeah the Steam summer
fest there's like steam fests like I
think there's an Autumn Fest and like
summer fest and a Spring Fest um you can
get onto those and you can like rent out
booths at at like game events like so
you know that's open to anyone if you
just say I want to buy a booth you pay
the money you go along yeah um those are
very expensive and they very rarely
translate to wish lists and wish list is
really what your metric is for knowing
whether or not you've got something
that's going to be uh financially
successful so yeah marketing is its
whole again that's a whole another yeah
no it is stream marketing it absolutely
is yeah it's so much easier for me to
sit there and make the game going well
there's nothing to Market if we don't
make the game yeah um but if I don't
Market it we won't sell it I think that
is the woe of creatives who are you
doing things on their own it's uh they
want to just create the thing and then
they're like w what I have to make sure
people see it now why has no one turned
up to this what the heck yeah yeah no
it's difficult now this will be our Q&A
section what sort of documents do you
have to organize the design of your to
do you have to organize the design of
your game do you have a game design
document an art Bible all that stuff so
yeah when I was at Uni they said that
games live and died by games design
Bible like you'll have a design document
and you'll have a game Bible and that's
how the industry works and that's what
that's what you're going to have to do
when I was making Focus fine by myself I
did the pitch deck which had everything
I needed to like explain the game to to
to Publishers but I didn't have any
resources put in a certain file format
so that someone else could look at it
and understand what was going on most of
it was in my head and like the images
that has reference images I just add in
like a reference image folder the Nar
narrative influences they were just
living in my head I didn't need to write
them down because they were things that
I knew the research that I did for the
game you know it's I think of it as
similar to the most similar game is like
um Thomas Was Alone and so i' played the
game I knew the game i' wasn't working
with anyone else so I didn't need to
write that down um it wasn't until I
then started working uh with jump bone
Studio that that and and other artists
that they needed to know this
information luckily by that time I'd
already the demo for Focus find so it
was just a lot of video clips um in a
document uh in like a folder was like
here's the mechanic here's how the
mechanic Works here's a video of the
mechanic working so we don't have like a
game design Bible as such we've got like
Google drive folder with lots of
subfolders the coder can go and look at
the mechanics folder but they still have
access to all the other ones the artists
have all the art folders where there'll
be like photoshop brushes uh and again
everyone will have access to like the
scripts and Nar narrative folder where
I've written the versions of the script
and they all help everyone do their job
properly but it's not like a Bible it's
it's a drive it's a Google drive with
relevant information I did try to write
a bit of a game Bible for someone that
was on boarding at the time I think they
looked at it once didn't refer back to
it and it just never got used I'm not a
fan of game Bibles because it's a lot of
writing words where I could explain
easily much quicker by showing and
talking yeah no that's a good point yeah
cuz in a small team it's so easy to stay
on top of everything I think when you're
a creative person which game developers
are we all have our own ways of working
right I love writing so whenever I do
anything I always like write down some
sort of game design documentation or I
do like a flowchart or something first
because that's just how my mind works
whereas other people do not get creative
like that like some people just need to
dig right on in before they even to
figure out anything on paper and that's
perfectly fine too so yeah but you're
right about university cuz I was the
exact same in uni they told me you know
you have to have this massive like 10
plus page game design documentation and
yeah you don't really see it too much
when you are in the industry although
I'm a technical designer and I love
documentation so that kind of makes me
sad well this is this is it gets old
quick and if unless someone's unless
you've got resource set aside to update
the document yeah and it's it's rarely
going to be cost effective I I find when
you're looking for a publisher do you
have to do so in a physical environment
or are they available to talk to um
online as well um I don't also do you
know if being in a different country um
makes a difference yeah so over the last
sort of few years we're talking like 5
years it's really turned into like an
international part of the the industry
like public publishing in the old days
you'd have local Publishers Sprout up
near where there'd be like video game
studios so that when you'd have like the
separatists or people that would leave
like a big video game Studio they would
set up their own little Studio the
publisher would need would be nearby so
that you could go in and have like face
to- face talks since Co and lockdown we
are now in a situation where you've got
Publishers that are doing International
deals so they're and they're making
deals without speaking direct face to
face with the people people it's it's
always better because you're always
buying off people like companies are
just shells uh and it's people that work
in the companies that you do business
with you know the again it's more about
the more you put yourself out there the
more someone's going to get a better
idea of who you are and so the more
attractive you are going to be to
Publishers so you can totally do that
digitally so you can be at any part of
the world and still get funding for your
indie game you don't have to travel
across the world and have that money up
front to um to get a publishing deal
it's not necessary how how would uh an
indie Dev with a demo and everything
ready to go what would their first step
to find a publisher to get in touch with
be where would they find them understand
what Publishers are in the space um and
you've got to understand what sort of
portfolio they have to understand
whether or not they're the sort of uh
publisher that are going to take on your
game so you've got to be into like the
indie game scene so you got to look at
steam a lot and figure out who the
Publishers are there were like the big
rockstar names like devolver that
everyone's heard of so those are like
the big like golden eggs if you will
there's websites with literally lists of
Publishers that you can find online I
listen to like podcasts and I'm part of
like Discord servers some really good
ones is indie game business they have
talks on very regularly from Publishers
and they talk about what sort of games
they're looking for and like their their
process there's Discord servers like how
to Market in indie game by Chris
sukowski he deep dives into like steam
algorithms he's not a direct resource
but going through his Discord and
watching his tutorials you get to see
that there's people in the industry
there they talk about things and and
again it's it's through who you know so
there there will be Publishers that pop
up in and around that sort of that sort
of thing and so yeah join a lot of
Discord servers and come up with a list
like literally have a list of top
Publishers you want to work with don't
talk to them first you have to talk to
like the Third Rate ones first just
us because also when you start your not
be get involved with as many of these
types of communities as possible to see
who's out there what the options are and
then from then you can specifically see
how to get in touch with whoever you
have decided would be good to talk to
yeah if you've got a game chances are
it's similar to other games research
what those games are and find out who
published them how can you keep keep
your sanity when people around you are
demotivating you and if so how did you
not let that get you
down uh I showed my mom the game when I
was making it and she said oh it doesn't
have any guns oh sorry Mom did you want
a violent hacken slash she she had in
her mind that video games to be fair
like when I was living with her as a
teenager the games I was playing was
like shoot a game so I I guess that's
where that that came from but yeah no
I've not had any people around me that
have been sort of discouraging about the
game I've had some people that have been
very Frank with me and people that have
given me some like tough love and told
me what they really think about the game
um and the standard it was in back when
I I did it just by myself and they're
totally right but they were coming at it
from a a good place like want to do
better to succeed I guess the best
advice I can I can give is try your best
not to surround yourself with people
that don't support you because um your
friends are the people that can
commiserate your defeats and celebrate
your successes so if they can't do that
then they're not really your friends
yeah I 100% agree with you I always try
and surround myself with people who are
both supportive and also usually have
their own Endeavors or creations and
it's it's nice to kind of bounce off
those types of people when you created a
vertical slice well first of all they
said did you create one and you did we
know you did uh so how close was it in
style and quality to what you expected
from like to have at
release so vertical slice gets its name
uh from you imagining it you are
literally got the finished article and
you taking a slice out of the middle of
it it's supposed to be as close to the
finished article as you could possibly
get it it's supposed to be able to test
the limitations of like Graphics of
everything so you've got to test the
boundaries of of the best graphics you
can get out of it like the best art you
can get visually it's got to look what
it's going to look like at the end the
sound has got to be at a professional
level as what it would be like at the
end of the game so I've been doing
scratch vocals for one of the charact
for some of the characters in in in the
ver in the new version of the vertical
slice we're doing and that won't ever
get released to the public like we're
going to get voice actors in to do that
because it needs to be at professional
level so it it needs to be a
representation of um the finished
article for it to be considered a
vertical slice how did you decide how
much money to ask for when you were
initially pitching your game it was
quite easy for a single solo Dev to ask
for money because all I needed to do was
figure out um how much how long it was
going to take to make and then what my
wage was going to be indie game Business
book I think it was published with biffl
games and it goes into things like burn
rates so there's like whole like bizdev
um money Spiel which I could go into
basically say I was going to do um a
pitch deck and you get to the to the
budget slide you need to be able to
demonstrate uh effectively to a
publisher that you're accurately
guessing how much money you need to
finish the game and the way you do that
is by you multip you get your burn rate
which is how much one developer costs
over a certain amount of time which is
basically like their wage so if the
game's going to take one year to make
and they're on £50,000
and you've got three developers then
your budget is
£150,000 to make the game so you need to
have every single cost to figure that
out there are lots of different deals I
could have made so if they were a
marketer
uh I could have kept the intellectual
property rights to the game and I could
have taken like a slice I could sell my
intellectual property rights to the
company and take a different slice there
are lots of different funding methods so
the budget is one number which how how
much the game will take to cost
sometimes that can come in different
packages so a publisher could sometimes
do half up front and then half at a
different Milestone again it depends on
how far away you are through development
do you have to have a figure when you
when you go in to have that initial
discussion yeah okay so you would come
in with a figure and you would just
figure that out well you being a solo de
figured that out by figuring out how
long you think you had left and how much
you wanted to get paid and then that
would obviously then lead on to a wider
discussion of what they could offer you
and yeah exactly yeah so all you have to
be able to demonstrate is that you have
thought about how long you think it's
going to take to make the game and how
much that will cost for all the
development costs so if it's a small
Team all the all the all the development
costs and you need to be able to be
correct like you need to be kind of
right if you lowball it that's a red
flag uh because if you lowball it that's
going to be taken out of the developers
salaries and if the if the salaries are
too low developers will be put off if
you highball it and you just go I'm I
think my company in this game is worth
like 2 million it's my first ever game
you're not going to be taken seriously
because you need to be able to prove it
and if you've not made made a game
before you have nothing to be able to
back that up and if you have made a game
before chances are it hasn't made a
million pounds and so you've you've made
yourself look silly by saying this I
want a million pounds for this game so
it needs to be it needs to be correct it
doesn't need to be 100% accurate it just
needs to be in the ballpark of correct
gotcha in your opinion how viable is
patreon and or Kickstarter as a method
to get funding very um I was was
considering uh doing a Kickstarter at
one point and I have considered patreon
as well they are totally viable and
Kickstarter is kind of coming back into
fashion as well there's some there's
some data to suggest that there's for
small Indie teams Kickstarter is
actually a good way to go they have
their downsides so for example some
Publishers won't be interested if you
have have a patreon or a Kickstarter
because of how they operate like there's
a whole another question around
budgeting and money and IP and wages it
makes it all a lot more complicated but
some will be put off by that not many
and the good ones won't be but again if
you're starting out and you're new and
you've got a patreon a Kickstarter it
might be those ones that will get you
foot in the door yeah that might be put
off second of all you can't rush either
a patreon or a Kickstarter so a
Kickstarter you'll take between about 30
days to 90 days to get all your ducks in
a row to have a a successful Kickstarter
so you need to launch a Kickstarter
around an event like a demo or a trailer
or an alpha build or like play testing
or not really release but all of those
uh are good reasons to to plan your
Kickstarter because you want to have the
maximum amount of press Buzz about it
and you want to have the most amount of
reason for someone to to join a
Kickstarter patreon is a Time sync so
patreon is a bit like running a YouTube
channel or doing a twitch stream
it takes dedication and it takes
repetition and you have to budget time
which is your most precious resource oh
and I will also say Kickstarter um yeah
it's very good I am also going to be
interviewing in the future someone who I
know has successfully funded a film um
but just like you said they the only
reason they could make the successful
kickstar it was because they made their
first film on their own and that was
successful so they said hey I made this
first film if you want to help me make a
sequel and you know so like you say
there needs to be something uh like a
reason for people to want to give money
uh and that's how he made it work so
yeah a great answer do you think it's a
slippery slope what's the bridge between
giving someone being a downer and giving
constructive
criticism construct to me I learn at
University that the definition of
constructive criticism cause effect and
solution so if people are saying I don't
like that
line that's not very helpful if they
don't tell you how to how to fix it and
what effect is having on them so if you
ask them for to be specific and drill
down into what they actually mean uh
it's going to be useful the other way to
think about criticism is that people can
be the meanest meanest meanest and
unfortunately on some level they're
always always right because criticism is
always personal it's that individuals
opinion and that individual's opinion is
correct you just have to put it in
perspective of what percentage of
everyone's opinion is that and weigh
that against what effect will it be to
to take note of that opinion and do
something about it and that's why when
you get lots of demos you get more
accurate representation of what the game
is actually like rather than just little
nitpicky bits of of certain individuals
yeah I always find with constructive
criticism I think it's quite it's quite
to know when someone's giving something
to you with the best intentions because
you know they'll they'll explain to you
how things could change or how to help
um instead of just going this is boring
this sucks yeah you suck I don't like
your game this is rubbish yeah okay
thanks for that can can I do things
better no oh okay yeah never mind I do
do a different game oh okay yeah give up
oh
okay yeah not the best advice did you
worry about finding the right balance
regarding making sure you budgeted for
enough Dev time/ marketing was there
back and forth with the publisher was
the publisher knowledgeable so it's not
the publisher it's the studio in in uh
your case yeah yeah yeah there there is
a back and forth so there's a discussion
about for Focus fine specifically
because I was making one game and then
we had the ability to to increase the
budget and therefore make a different
game it was mainly conversations about
what that game would look like and how
it would be different to the original
version of the game and then there was
discussions about what resources were
available at the studio and therefore
what we could what sort of game we could
accommodate so we were it was
conversations back and forth about what
uh we could come up with with the people
we had the money didn't really come into
it it was the money was just basically
talking about what my wage would be
can't really get into details but that
long and short of it is that I wasn't
involved in the discussion of What's the
total budget for this game all I was
involved with was um what am I going to
do who am I going to work with and how
much you going to get paid that's that's
the discussion I had if I was talking to
a
publisher I would have gone back and
forth and then we would have talked
about what the total budget of the game
would be I know what the total budget
folks find is but it doesn't really
affect my job too much um and when you
make a deal it it doesn't really affect
your job that much like what the total
budget is how far how far you are
through the budget does but that's what
a producer's role is so a producer's
role is to to like take care of that
side of things and if people change and
if budgets change and if things come and
go then it's the producers role to um
like sort that all out so me as a like
game lead I don't really have to get
into the Weeds about that sort of thing
luckily um but if I was going to do a
pitch to to a a publisher you don't need
to know too much other than what the
total budget is and what your costs are
and what your team's costs are and
everything else they don't expect you to
know what be an expert in so it's fine
also how do you rationalize the amount
of time you think a game will take you
that's a really difficult question
that's really common question there's no
method other than practice um so you
just have to uh get good at logging your
time write down how long it took you how
to polish this level how long it took
you to design that level how long it
took you to do sound effects for 20% of
the game how long um it took you to come
like do the code for for half of the
mechanics it's only when you've got that
number that you can then double it or
triple it for the remainder of what's on
your list so you you'll have a a list of
mechanics you'll have a list of art
assets you'll have a list of everything
you need to make in the game and once
You' figured out how much things take to
do you can do the sums and do the math
and then make a prediction it will be
wrong but that's the best we have in the
industry and there is there is no
precise science to it and it's just
through experience you get better at it
and even then there's always like a 20
to 30% margin of error and you always
plan uh you always put 20% on everything
so you put 20% on time put 20% on budget
uh for things to run over um because we
we we're in the industry of of creating
things that have never been uh made
before so we're the the good games are
are new and Innovative and that that
takes time what advice would you give
someone who's currently looking to fund
their game just one one piece of small
advice what would it be put yourself out
there that's the best piece of advice I
can give because everything good that's
come my way with Focus find has been
from doing that through one way or
another uh and the more you can put
yourself out there the The Wider you net
you're casting the better what is next
for you and focus find and also where
can chat find you as well and your game
Focus find is available to wish list on
Steam you can find me through uh
searching for acrylic pixel so that's my
company name and that's like my name on
Twitter or and Instagram Tik Tok is
where I share most of the uh updates on
the game as well honestly you've given
such amazing responses I'm going to be
thinking about all you said tonight and
um yeah I really appreciate you coming
on here and just sharing your wealth of
knowledge cuz you are a
fountain thank you I haven't been doing
it long so take everything I say with a
pinch of salt you know oh dude I am so
impressed by the amount that you've
taught yourself especially just during
lockdown and you know I just made a game
because I wanted to learn how to code
and then I just thought I'll make an MVP
ah I'll just like you know put Pitch
Teck together just get in coner with the
few I think that's amazing and I love
your mindset about it all as well um you
reminding yourself of why you started
and just not being afraid to take risks
and now you've become a full-time indie
game developer on the game you birthed
you're a daddy to
two I have two children yeah you do so
congratulations it's awesome thanks okay
thank you so much everyone for watching
I hope you learned a lot and I hope
you're as inspired as I feel right now I
know it's been a really tough time for
the games industry lately who knows you
know your future could lie in indie game
development and now you know quite a bit
more thanks to Chris so have a lovely
dear evening I'll see you next
time thank you so much to my patreons
for making this video possible thanks
October Knight games Bruce Barrett
Salvatore marfield G with Malachi 79
Dave Smith Stuart Cherry I 196 and Quinn
Darko